all right so with online sales as we get
into the holiday season online sales
breaking records this year there's a new
study that predicts package thefts well
they're also going to rise well those
crimes constant problem nationwide we
talk about them all the time maybe it's
happened to you there are some ways to
protect yourself hector mejia live this
morning and hector we learned that you
had your deodorant stolen so now you can
take these tips and help yourself it
smells horrible
that is true good morning guys and it's
never fun trying to figure out what
happened to your packages and we've
learned they're arriving early this year
with sales already underway you know all
of last year some 20 billion of these
packages were shipped all across the
country and a new study by cctv camera
world ranks nevada number 22 where you
are least likely to have a package
stolen they say you should still be
aware so they come through fbi crime
data for 2020 they pointed to a study
saying that 43 percent of those surveyed
all across the country reported having a
package stolen at least once that
actually went up from the year before
and almost two-thirds said it happened
to them more than once so this year
people are protecting their packages in
a number of ways you can sign up for
tracking and text alerts this feature
will notify you when your items arrive
you can also invest in what's being
called a porch lock box those are
designed with a code that you give to
the delivery service and then they lock
up your items when they arrive you can
also have your packages sent to work to
an amazon locker just choose in-store
pickup and of course you can also use
surveillance cameras and also consider
staying home if you can to make sure
you're there when your delivery arrives
reporting live this morning hector mejia
live local now okay good advice watch
for those boxes keep an eye out thanks
hector appreciate it